this is an imagined week in mr. woods
like I said what give mister wearing
funny clothes for Lydia an imagined week
what you through plastic seven days of
sales of a quarter store that's situated
near the beach okay so what I happen to
be selling these are these are sales of
Pyro's cuz they need a beat okay is
bottles of sunscreen and ice creams
because see pastel because I made the
beach right good boy
so this is how an imagined week at my
corners don't progressive these are the
different kinds of sales that I made now
I regardless of whether in a big
advantage for this so clear structure to
my sale of sunscreen and less no ice
creams and in fact you can kind of see
there must be linked in some way right
for instance as I have more sales in
sunscreen right I also have more sales
in ice creams like my smallest day right
for sales of sunscreen well obviously
there's zero zero okay but here three
that corresponds to the lowest number of
ice creams and by the highest number of
sales or cell phones on the sunscreen
also corresponds to my highest number
sales of ice cream so there's clearly
some kind of relationship so if we call
sunscreen s and we call ice creams by
right
how would we express this relationship
that's not that hard to work out in this
imagined week what kind of relationship
we can fall for instance have a look at
all of these sunscreen numbers
what do they all have in common
they are all yeah whose were three there
are multiples of three okay
so if I were to take the number of moles
of sunscreen I solved right yes and if I
were to divide that by three I would get
a number right I'd get one three four
seven two right so that's the number of
moles in such been divided by three and
those numbers they're related to these
numbers right if I have it my head one
three four seven two these numbers are
also special right what kind of number
love it they're all square numbers all
right so says two reason I should like
kind of take the square root here okay
so I take the square root of all of
these numbers the square root of R I'm
going to get 2 4 5 8 3 right it's a look
right divided by 3 square root divided
by 3 to get 1 square root of 2/3 + 3
square root 4 divided by 3 that's 4
square root fine you can start to see a
pattern right if I divide this by 3 it's
really exactly the same thing as if I
take the square root and I have to take
off 1 right because the square root of
this number is not exactly the same as
this number by the battery but tada I
have a relationship right I can say
I can say if you like I could make the
subject s and I could say well I can
work out how many bottles of sunscreen I
ought to expect to sell if I've already
got a number about ice creams I've
solved a square root take away one and
then I multiply that number by three
okay so what we have created it here
yeah he's really put a bit of extra
notation right it's sunscreen as a bless
you as a function of ice cream does that
make sense right it's sunscreen I have
an expression for that in terms of ice
cream okay and I can get a number out
and at least in my favorite get years on
if accurate okay
now it's all fine it makes the miracle
sense the only problem is it's
ridiculous correct because there's no
rule that says oh you know people are
buying sunscreen I guess I'd better buy
ice creams right there's not really up
you know people people start is the
sales of sunscreen to skyrocket quick
quick buy ice cream or vice versa right
that doesn't make sense okay as you can
see by the way I didn't have to make
sunscreen a function of ice cream I
could have made how would I do it if I
wanted to make ice cream a function of
sunscreen what I do here I had one right
so that would give me the spirit of my
being S on three plus one and then I
guess I'm swear right so that would give
me this okay so what is what you the
other what is the function y ella no big
deal right it just doesn't make sense
with reality okay
in fact what's missing from
is that both of these they're not
related to each other but they're not
related to each other it's that they're
both rising and falling in response to
some other information that's not on
here some other piece of data of which
next to the beach you might be able to
guess is probably something like
sunshine weather temperature something
like that right so for instance if you
take your table and precise if you add
another color
my suspicions okay now if for instance I
sit beside all of these patients beside
these months I have another measurement
right let's for the sake of simplicity
let's call it temperature okay and if I
go ahead and I look up the actual you
know recording time for each day suppose
I get something like this
okay so because I have this extra
measurement right this extra metric if
you like right but what actually
happened to give the situation really as
temperature rises that's what causes
both of these two eyes okay it's not
that sunscreen rising makes more sales
of ice cream okay it's that when
temperature rises both of these rise at
the same time hey does that make sense
so it's really this which is in control
so even though I could say this and it
would be accurately I would get the
right job job it actually makes more
sense to say I can write sunscreen as a
function of temperature and I can write
ice creams as a function of temperature
right both of these things actually have
a root cause right so we've seen this
function notation before right you used
to see f of X or whatever okay but you
could use any letters you like and since
my functions actually refer to objects
on bodies what made my functions after
my objects
what would sunscreen be as a function of
temperature you have a look okay for
instance you saw there was division by
300 right okay now when you get one
three four seven - how do they relate to
these numbers it's a good question
that's a very good question
we will we will cover that in a second I
just think that that's probably
something realistic it's three two
degrees I don't think it's any huge
number of people you know oh I have a
look right for instance I can see that
these numbers here right are exactly it
looks to be 25 a pot here right sorry
when I divide this by three I'm gonna
get one which is 27 pot whatever I this
by three that's going to be 27 part to
this and we're going to write this by
three every 27 part do you see what's
going on here okay so when I divide by
three that's the same as taking 27 way
for this
yes okay so another way of saying that
he is you can take the temperature
subtract 27 and then if you multiply
that by 3 that's how many moles of
sunscreen others le yes good question we
get it okay you can clearly see this
URIs seem to be following a different
kind of rule but then right they just
like they just do it there okay
okay so we'll we'll come to that in a
second that's sunscreen now help me out
with ice creams right something has to
be squared the question is what you
remember you told me there was an offset
of 1 okay this one up here right yes
instead of doing t minus 27
I think I should go to minus 26 right T
most amazing so for instance here I will
get 2 you scratch you get forward here
I'm going to get 4 u squared you get 16
here I'm going to get when I say take my
dream GTA 5 slightly at we fire okay so
this makes sense tell you yeah that's
right so you take this number as all
settings and then you square it which is
the equivalent of this square here